the saints reboot is finally here and
even though the game is pretty
self-explanatory there are a couple
things that took me a while to figure
out and i want you to skip that step so
here are seven things i wish i knew when
i first started playing saints row
one thing you should know about me is
that i love to spend about an hour with
the game's character creator it's the
perfectionist in me i'm also guilty of
restarting games because i don't like
the way my character looks but whether
you're like me or not i'm here to tell
you that you shouldn't spend more than 5
minutes in the saints row character
creator for starters the boss factory
demo aka the creation tools were out
months before the game so you should
have already spent hours recreating
yourself my other reason for saying this
is because you'll have all of the same
options at your disposal at any point in
the game the only exceptions are when
you're driving and flying otherwise you
can be in the middle of a gunfight
editing the size of your hips as you get
shot it's also worth noting that your
character is going to be in a uniform
with a helmet on for the entire first
mission so it doesn't really matter what
they look like pick a voice that you
think you'll want to hear for those
initial dialogue sequences and just drop
right into the action guns blazing
see i'm flanking left as ordered
when i started saints row on console i
was immediately dissatisfied with the
sensitivity of my aim and was equally
disappointed when i could not find an
option to lower it unbeknownst to me the
option was in fact available just not
where i expected it to be initially i
was looking in the controls menu for
ways to change my aim but that only
provided a stick dead zone option so for
a while my workaround was to go into
options gameplay and then challenge
options this menu not only lets you dial
in the difficulty of things like vehicle
combat and enemy durability but you can
also customize how much help the game's
aim assist will be the default lock on
type is short lock but i found that
switching to full lock was exactly what
i needed to start enjoying combat more
some players might even benefit from
leaving it on short lock but increasing
the lock-on attraction to wide however
if you'd rather change the sensitivity
like i wanted to at first that option is
hidden in the camera settings there's
duplicate menu options all over the
place but for some reason sensitivity
only shows up in this one spot
a large chunk of building your criminal
empire in saints row comes from starting
businesses and using them as fronts for
illegal activity these businesses called
criminal ventures in game can often be
the key to unlocking new story missions
and side activities like insurance fraud
so i'd advise buying as many as you can
early on during my playthrough i was
locked out of a mission with eli and
could not figure out why that was the
case until i finally returned to the
criminal ventures table and realized
what i had to build was there as an
option and even though these businesses
can be pricey don't think of it as a
waste of your hard-earned cash because
they all make you hourly income once
they're up and running it won't be long
before you've earned back what you spent
and then some especially if you
eliminate the threats around each one
because that increases the hourly income
that can be earned just don't forget to
transfer your funds from the cash app on
your in-game phone
fast travel in saints row isn't hard but
it's not completely obvious so other
than your apartment and eventually the
saints hq you can teleport to four
additional points in santo aliso these
points are marked by a purple icon with
a subway car as the image to activate
these points you'll need to take a
picture of the landmark there seems
simple enough right well during my
playthrough i ran into a small issue
where the guidelines weren't showing up
for me this was mostly a problem at the
panther rock fast travel point to fix
this i just walked around the path a
little bit away from the exact point
that the icon was showing on the map and
then it finally triggered the photo to
work but hopefully this was just a small
pre-launch issue that was fixed with the
game's day one patch
stealing cars is cool and all but owning
one is even cooler why because you can
customize the car and make it your own
no more nabbing brenda's car at a red
light and having to be seen driving
around with her lame rims this is why
garages are your best friend at the
start of the game there's one right next
to your apartment building you can store
cars here and access them anytime you
return after that you'll find an auto
body shop of sorts on the side of the
church that can be used for the same
purpose but at this point you'll also
have gym rob's garage as well
unfortunately both of these are on the
same side of the city so you have to
drive whatever you want to keep all the
way around to either location but these
garages can do more than storing cars
and making them look nice they are also
where you can upgrade cars alongside the
upgrades are signature abilities special
for lack of a better term abilities that
can be unlocked by completing challenges
associated with that vehicle i overlook
these way longer than i care to admit so
i suggest you take advantage of them as
soon as you can because some of them are
capable of adding a small layer of
variety to the traversal and vehicle
combat
it took me way too long to upgrade my
weapons during my playthrough this
wasn't a huge inconvenience as it didn't
cause me to constantly fail missions but
the fact is stronger weapons make combat
a little bit more fun so don't just look
at friendly fire gun shops around town
as places to purchase new weapons look
at them as a place to customize and
upgrade your arsenal as well similar to
vehicles weapons also have signature
abilities and friendly fire is one spot
you can enable those abilities for each
weapon as you unlock them and in order
to do that you have to complete the
challenges associated with that weapon
the stagecoach shotgun for example has a
buffalo shot ability that can be
unlocked by killing five martial
gunslingers with the stagecoach the
faster you complete the challenge the
faster you have access to just one more
way of making you an unstoppable force
two useful parts of saints row are
skills and perks that can be equipped
once unlocked after completing special
challenges something that i wish i did
immediately upon starting the game is
completing these challenges on purpose
what i mean by this is a handful of
these challenges are finished over time
by just simply playing the game for
example making a purchase at a shop or
traveling a certain distance by car or
by foot i reached each of these goals
passively but if i looked over the
objectives and finished them on purpose
instead i could have leveled up my
character and unlocked the skills and
perks associated with each level of
challenge much quicker so those are the
things i wish i knew when i first
started playing saints rock they aren't
completely game changing but each one is
enough to save you a decent amount of
time early on so what are some of the
things that took you way too long to
figure out that would help someone else
let us know in the comments and like
this video if you found it helpful at
all you can find me on twitter at
devonta chisholm thanks for watching
oh
foreign